separate their waste for recycling into
the different boxes and then the crew
come along and they have separated again
into the correct compartment on the
lorry here at the bulking station the
materials are unloaded into individual
Bay's before being prepared for
transportation to the recycling
factories let's take a look inside so
here we have our huge paper mountain
it's only taken three days for us to
collect this amount of paper each month
we can collect over 300 tons of
newspapers magazines paper that's from
householders and from recycling banks
when you consider it takes 15 trees to
make just one ton of paper
we're potentially saving over 4,500
trees every month this paper will be
collected and taken to Alfred and Kent
to a huge paper mill where it'll be
recycled into new newsprint did you know
it only takes seven days for a newspaper
to be recycled into a new one
all of the glass bottles and jars that
are collected in your green curbside
recycling boxes will be bought here to
the bulking station it will then be
transported to abel mouth where by using
special lasers they will be able to
separate the glass into the different
colors once separated it can then be
sent to various factories throughout the
UK to be made into new glass bottles and
jars did you know that if you recycle
just one of these glass jars you will
save enough energy to power a television
for one and a half hours
so here you can see all of the aluminium
cans and aerosols that we've collected
through the black curbside recycling box
once they're here at the Vulcan station
we have to separate the aluminium cans
from the steel cans and we do this using
a huge Council to machine with the
magnetic belt inside it can separate the
two materials and then it crushes them
and we can put them into bales which
makes it easy for transporting the
aluminium cans were taken to Warrington
where they'll be melted down amazing to
just simply new aluminium cans steel
cans we sent to port Tolbert and they
will also be melted down and used to
make new food for drink
here we have the plastic bottles that
have been collected in your green
recycling box as you can see we have a
mixture of plastics we have colored
plastic we have cloudy plastic and we
have clear plastic
these will be squashed using large
compacting machine and put into bales
for they're much easier to transport
they'll then be taken to a factory in
Wigan where they'll be shredded and put
into tiny pieces and sold to companies
to make new products such as new drink
bottles you may not believe it but my
fleece jacket here was actually made
from 25 plastic bottles amazing
when you take a look around this bulking
station you can see the huge piles
materials that been collected from
householders across the district for
recycling if we hadn't have separated
this waste to be recycled it would have
all been sent to the local landfill site
which could be falling about eight or
nine years time when you bury things in
landfill they can take hundreds and
hundreds of years to disappear or break
down for example this cloudy plastic
bottle could take up to 500 years before
it disappears in the landfill site not
only you saving space in the landfill
but you're also saving raw materials
that would have been needed to have made
this new plastic bottle if we hadn't
have recycled it so next time you throw
something in the bin make sure you're
throwing it in the right one and think
about your impact on the environment